[Music]
hello june hello jennifer
i've recorded some questions here and
i've left enough space for you to answer
[Music]
what do you think of your new school
which do you like better
sunshine or rain
that was your day girls
he spoke to me and then it was just less
and less you know
if there's something you want to
communicate
you best say it now
[Music]
jennifer
john
how would you describe your
personalities i think you might be a bad
influence on each other it might be an
idea to split you up for a while
we will move the girls into special
education i want to say anything we'll
get them to talk guilty or not guilty
you need to take care of us because
please say something how do you
plead they shall be institutionalized
indefinitely
[Applause]
if you were telling your story
how would it begin
in order to try out a good book you need
to feel it you have to be inspired
[Music]
right
[Music]
i now bear life without my sister
it's brought on you awakening in me i
could reach out and touch the stars i
could see the galaxy i can't go back to
the empty days before we finally feel as
though i'm swimming in a pool taste a
the bittersweet smell of salt
it's like god gave me a chance to get
a challenge to prove who i really am
[Music]
you